[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
musician marilyn manson accused of
sexually assaulting evan rachel wood
why the actor turned activist says she's
coming forward now
i was deeply terrified and that fear
lives with me to this day singer mariah
carey is being sued by her own
sister and a suspect in an infamous
hijacking case
dies experts say the true identity
behind the d.b cooper case
may never be known if they had had
substance information
i think they would have slapped the
cuffs on him plus a new hampshire man
charged with killing a minister
points the finger at another suspect we
break down the defense's legal arguments
i do think there's potentially
exculpatory evidence in there
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long prime daily
i'm jesse weber along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
snow's keeping brian stuck in once again
but i know he'll be back in the studio
soon in the meantime let's get started
actor and activist evan rachel wood is
now
publicly accusing musician marilyn
manson of sexual abuse
wood took to instagram writing the name
of my abuser
is brian warner also known to the world
as marilyn manson
he started grooming me when i was a
teenager and horrifically abused me for
years
wood's relationship with manson became
public in 2007
when she was 19 and he was 38.
they were briefly engaged manson
responded on instagram
saying these claims about him are
horrible distortions of reality
my intimate relationships have always
been entirely consensual
with like-minded partners his record
label has since dropped him
wood testified in front of congress in
2018 to advocate for the survivor bill
of rights act
while she didn't name her accuser then
she described
a harrowing tale of assault toxic mental
physical and sexual abuse which started
slow but escalated over time including
threats against my life
severe gaslighting and brainwashing
waking up to the man that claimed to
love me raping what he believed to be my
unconscious body
and the worst part sick rituals of
binding me up by my hands and feet to be
mentally and physically tortured until
my abuser felt i had proven my love for
them
all right let's get into it brian
california state senator susan rubio has
asked the doj to launch a probe
wrote a letter to the ag and the head of
the fbi how could that play out
yeah jesse the name of the game is
investigation they're going to look deep
into marilyn manson's past
and talk to miss wood as well as the
other women who came out on social media
saying that the allegations against
marilyn manson sorry
that would put out there seems very
similar to what happened to them the
next thing you're going to find out is
whether or not these allegations fit
within the statute of limitations and if
they do
they're going to go forward with charges
you know terry he's currently not
charged but when you look at this case
and you look at cases like the harvey
weinstein
case or the bill cosby cases how is that
how are those cases going to affect a
potential prosecution
of marilyn manson i think they will have
a big effect those were the first sexual
assault cases of
really public figures and they were
widely publicized i think the issue here
is because of that publicity jurors or
prospective doers
they are going to know that it is okay
they might feel comfortable going ahead
and
convicting someone who has had this type
of history because it's been done before
the other issue is if there are other
women and we see now that these other
women are
claiming that they too were assaulted
they might actually have to consider
the prior bad acts under 404 and whether
or not they can get these
other women to testify in this case if
in fact there are charges brought
yeah and it'll be interesting to see if
anybody else comes forward what evidence
there might be this could just be the
beginning of something
very large to come like we saw when the
new york times broke that story on
harvey weinstein so
it's a very interesting story but in
other celebrity legal news and there's a
bunch
singer mariah carey is being sued by her
estranged sister for more than one
million dollars
the pop star sister is claiming that she
was publicly humiliated in the sister's
new book entitled
the meaning of mariah carey carey
claimed her older sister
alison carey drugged her with valium
when she was 12 years old and
let her go for a ride with the older
sister's boyfriend who was carrying a
gun
the singer also claims that alison
burned her with boiling tea
according to court documents allison
carey says she was never given a chance
to respond
and that the singer has presented no
evidence to substantiate the allegations
now terry here's what's interesting
about this because allison carey is
suing her sister under a theory called
intentional infliction of emotional
distress how do you prove that
you know intentional infliction of
emotional distress is a plaintiff's
dream cause of action especially when
all
else fails because the elements are
relatively easy to demonstrate
first of all all they have to show is
that it was intentional
that the conduct was extreme and that
that
conduct caused severe emotional distress
so if allison can show
that mariah intentionally tried to hurt
her and that these words
did in fact cause her emotional distress
she will
have a viable claim i'm not saying she's
going to win but she will survive
a motion to dismiss based on a failure
to state a cause of action well brian i
turn it to you she's demanding 1.25
million dollars do you think that she
has a
successful claim here and enough to get
that much
i don't think that's going to be a
successful claim as terry already laid
out those are the elements but
when we talk about mariah carey's intent
in writing this book what is it about
it's about her
getting uh some of her trials and
tribulations off her chest not to
directly harm her sister
and i think what's gonna happen to the
sister she's gonna find out in order to
have this claim to show that there's
intentional emotional distress
she may have to come forward and say
were these allegations true
did this actually happen and that might
poke a
hornet's nest that she might not be
willing to actually play around with
wow well we have some more news out of
hollywood and
this one actually involves the hollywood
sign
believe it or not because six people
have been arrested
after scaling the iconic landmark in an
apparent attempt to
change the letters to read holly boob
the los angeles police department says
that it was a stunt done to
try to raise breast cancer awareness
five men and one woman were seen
trekking through the steep terrain
a police helicopter quickly launched to
see the changing letters
and the six people are now facing
charges of trespassing
what a story a former nfl player
has pleaded not guilty to felony
domestic assault charges
for allegedly attacking his girlfriend
chad wheeler was released from his
position as offensive lineman for the
seattle seahawks
following his arrest king county
prosecutors say wheeler viciously
attacked the victim
choking her until she lost consciousness
the victim reportedly told authorities
that when she awoke
wheeler said quote wow you're alive the
altercation allegedly began after the
victim refused to bow to wheeler
the trial scheduled to begin on april
6th
still ahead on long crime daily police
in california now searching for more
potential witnesses of an accused serial
rapist
but first an update to the story of a
nine-year-old pepper sprayed by police
the actions the department is now taking
after the break
[Music]
three rochester new york police officers
have been suspended
after officers handcuffed and pepper
sprayed a nine-year-old girl
the mayor of rochester said the
department moved immediately to remove
the three involved
officers from patrol duties the officers
were responding to a call of family
trouble on friday police body cam video
shows officers trying to get the girl
into a patrol car
but she repeatedly kicked and pulled at
them that's when an officer
officer is heard saying just sprayer at
this point
an internal investigation is now ongoing
into the incident
and we're going to show you the video
right now but we warn you it is
disturbing
wait can i just please get the snow off
of me i'll get the snorkeling let's go
in the car get in the car now okay
okay you've had your chances what are
you doing
what are you doing i want you we're
gonna go to jail now
you're up stop sit up you're acting like
a shot
a child
[Laughter]
that's tough to watch switching gears a
years-long investigation leads to the
arrest of a man suspected of raping
several young girls in california long
crime's angenette levy tells us why the
case
isn't closed
sheriff's deputies in san mateo county
just outside of san francisco
have been investigating the sexual
assault of multiple young girls
since 2012. now a witness has come
forward
and identified the rapist the suspect
has been identified as 30-year-old
kaylin freeman
who lives on the coast in san mateo
county detectives believe there are more
victims that have yet to come forward
freeman is accused of using social media
apps to find his victims
and luring them with drugs sheriff's
office detectives are looking for any
information regarding kailyn freeman
and any information from anyone who's
been victimized by kailyn freeman
right now kalyn freeman faces a laundry
list of charges including rape and
stalking
and more charges could be coming for law
and crime daily
i'm angenette levy okay now brian
this case pretty remarkable because it
almost went
cold right what are your thoughts on
this
yeah it's really interesting because at
one point this case they had no leads
they had suspects they they had victims
they believed they had ties to who this
person would be but it almost
went cold that wasn't until a witness
came forward and identified him and now
i think as we're
hearing there's going to be more and
more victims that step forward as
they're able to connect the dots as to
who that perpetrator is that harm them
but terry in this kind of case what
would freeman's
best defense be because as of right now
where it's looking it's not looking too
good for him
you know actually jesse he has several
defenses i think
first of all there's only been one
victim who's come forward so far
and she's identified him but what the
defense could say is
that it was a mistaken identity this was
too long ago you don't remember exactly
what it looked like
the other thing is that one thing i'm
sure they're going to claim is this was
over
a social media app he met her and others
through these apps and he may very well
try to say that it was
all consensual my only hope is that
if in fact he is the one that they do
get enough corroborating evidence
to actually proceed and convict him if
he's actually the one who did these
graves
well terry you're a great lawyer and
those are great arguments i don't know
for him with if more people start coming
forward and
you have social media evidence that's
documentary evidence i don't know but
you make some interesting arguments and
ultimately see where this case goes
because i know a lot of people are
watching that one
all right coming up on long crime daily
a suspect in a decades-old
skyjacking case passes away but the
mystery
remains unsolved plus how police say a
man got away with squatting in an
airport for
three months the rest video you don't
want to miss
[Music]
next
welcome back everybody one of the
suspects in the infamous db
cooper hijacking has died at the age of
94.
according to the fbi a nondescript man
calling himself dan
cooper bordered a flight in portland
oregon in 1971
and while on the plane the man demanded
200
000 dollars and took 36 people hostage
the plane landed cooper got his money
and then
made the plane take off again with just
the crew on board
cooper ordered course for mexico city
but somewhere in between seattle and
reno
he jumped out of the back of the plane
using a parachute
the fbi says among the list of suspects
was sheridan peterson
who once admitted that the fbi had good
reason to suspect him
forensic death investigator joseph scott
morgan says cooper disappeared
and his true identity remains unknown
it's fantastical almost that someone
could have survived
uh a jump like that uh you know when you
trace it back you see what kind of
elements had to be in place remember
they stopped this plane
uh he he had them land this plane uh the
infamous db cooper we don't know who's
who d.b cooper actually is and you know
had parachutes brought aboard uh had the
had the
the passengers disembarked from the
plane and then you're going to
do a jump uh of kind of a low altitude
jump
into this heavily forested area it's
always been a wonder that anyone could
survive
remember they did find particulate
pieces of
of these monies uh that were given to
him as as a demand
and uh they've been found over the years
in various uh
uh creek beds and that sort of thing so
look
stevie cooper's never gonna go away
never ever
and the mystery continues newly released
surveillance footage shows the arrest of
a man
accused of squatting at chicago o'hare's
airport for three months
prosecutors say two united airlines
employees
spotted aditya singh wearing an airport
badge
and when they reportedly asked him for
identification they realized that the
badge belonged to an employee who
reported it missing last october
police say singh told them that he was
scared to go home to
los angeles due to covid he said he
survived by asking passengers for food
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
says that singh faces up to five years
in prison
and the judge found it was really
concerning and she made a fabulous point
where these airports are supposed to be
so secure
especially post 911 we have all sorts of
regulations and restrictions in the
airports
so it's really surprising to learn that
somebody can just squat in an airport
for three months and we're lucky this
person was just scared of kovid which is
its own interesting issue but what if
this person would
have nefarious intentions or you know
had some sort of
uh you know malicious intent here that
could have been very very dangerous
this was a risk to the community that
someone was able to
uh impersonate airport personnel for so
long
i don't think that the state is going to
be inclined to dismiss
this case only because they're going to
want to send a message to the community
that you can't just squat in an
airport for three months and nothing
happened to you
um but here we have the non-violent
offender with
no criminal history uh i think he's got
a good shot of getting some leniency
if he decides to plead guilty and expect
accept responsibility in this case
all right scary stuff when we come back
a defendant
accused of shooting a minister then
praying over his body
what supposedly led to this assailant to
this assault and could there be
an alternative suspect our legal
analysts just ahead
a new hampshire man has pleaded not
guilty to fatally shooting a church
minister in 2019
a grand jury indicted brandon
castellioni for second degree murder of
louis garcia
pelham police say that garcia was
working to paint the home of the
defendant's father
when he was shot in the back of the head
the defendant's family
reported castiglione praying and crying
over the victim's body
less than two weeks later police say the
victim's stepson dale holloway went to
the church during
a wedding and shot a woman marrying the
defendant's father
and a minister both survived their
injuries but now castiglione's defense
attorneys
are requesting access to holloway's
discovery
has sort of taken this view that mr
holloway was there in the church
uh as a cause and effect of this case
but
we do not have to accept that um and
certainly again as i mentioned the fact
that someone 12 days later
went um to
shoot at the church to see the bishop
show to shoot at
uh other members of the church with mr
holloway this sort of background
i do think there's potentially
exculpatory evidence in there
to provide a motive or opportunity for
someone else to have caused the death of
mr garcia which is of course
what we plan on plan on arguing mr
castiglione had provided some guns
to mr garcia that mr garcia
was in uh possession of some of his guns
there's potentially some information
about
that um in the just just i just said
just because mr castiglidani's name does
not appear does not mean that there is
not a spoke before information
the fence maintains that their client is
innocent and says that there could be
information that points to holloway
as the possible shooter in both
incidents
but certainly there could be evidence
about any animosity that mr holloway may
have had towards mr garcia
um you know they were not biologically
related they were stepped
uh you know mr holloway was uh mr
garcia's stepson
uh potentially there was animosity
towards uh
mark pasciglioni brandon's father or the
church in general
um that maybe was was felt by
by mr hallway because i do think that is
what the state believes is the motive
for mr hallway but
potentially the real target
of uh of mr garcia's death
was marco stiglione was certainly in his
house
prosecutors rejected those claims and
say there's no
exculpatory information the judge is
expected to rule
at a later date we're back to
her argument of relatedness she doesn't
see
the harm in us providing it
there's still no reason for us to
provide it because there's
she hasn't identified any potentially
exculpatory evidence that's contained
within our file
other than this other than the
connection that i've already described
there's nothing
in the file and if she wants to present
a more
detailed account then perhaps the issue
should be reconsidered but
she specifically mentioned the gagne
standard which is
low but it's a standard and if we're
going to use that one
defense hasn't come close to meeting it
i feel that we should not
be compelled to provide this discovery
okay a lot to get in here uh terry let's
discuss this theory by the defense that
it was
holloway who killed garcia what do you
think about that
look whenever you can point the finger
to another person it creates reasonable
doubt in the minds of the jurors
you know and supposedly the victim louis
garcia and the defendant you know
brandon castiglioni
they were friends so the defense can say
there's no motive here so
i think that's an argument to make but
when i think about dale holloway
he was the stepson so what would his
motive be but
supposedly you know he was involved in
this second shooting and
maybe he had something against his
stepfather as a minister and the other
minister who was involved in the second
shooting so i suppose
it's an argument that the jury can make
brian let's talk about the gun really
quickly
the government is saying that
castiglione's fired the gun because his
fingerprints were on there but
how do you argue that away all right so
the best way to tell if someone fired
the gun
the bar none it's called gsr gunshot
residue when you fire a gun
the ballistics cause some of that debris
some of that
gun powder to come back on your hands
simply finding
fingerprints on a gun just means at one
point in time you touched it
and especially because there's no
fingerprints on the on the shell casing
you can argue that he may have touched
it at an earlier time but didn't fire it
i'll tell you this much juries love an
alternative suspect if the defense can
show that if they can present enough
evidence
they might have something it's a
complicated case but it'll be an
interesting one to follow to say the
least
all right everybody thanks for joining
us here on lawn crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you